je me suis rendu aujourd'hui à roy est
ici à saint-etienne du rouvray avec
madame la ministre des armées pour
m'assurer du déploiement des forces
sécurité et des forces militaires
supplémentaires que nous avons décidé
avec le président de la république de
déployer autour non seulement des lieux
de culte mais également des
établissements scolaires à l'avant
veille de la rentrée
nous avons également eu un échange avec
le préfet avec le maire sur pour nous
assurer que l'ensemble des dispositions
étaient bien prises pour assurer la
sécurité de ces lieux et de ces
événements je dois vous dire que vous
devez compter sur l'entière
détermination du gouvernement de la
république pour permettre à tous et à
chacun de pratiquer son culte en toute
sécurité et en toute liberté
notre volonté est forte notre
détermination ne faiblira pas c'est
l'honneur de la france c'est l'honneur
de la république